[Applause]
[Music]
you got your prospective
to be happy don't you want to be happy
[Music]
screenshots of tweets and Instagram
stories work so immediately with this
team not stretched in however to [ __ ]
you guys like rolling with each other
because it should be from the photo
person to the top to you like to me to
the intern like everybody should be able
to play cricket have you guys if you
guys slack it or what you do I really
want to get into the culture of creation
that's interesting philosophy like how
you take like a nugget of a story and
yeah just why it's energy right it's
momentum
it's of what happened with the Jets game
last night it's like sports is such a
great parallel like it's even and then a
couple things happened and it's over
momentum that's how it actually works
it's how your life actually works you
know it's hard to wrap your head around
energy so like thus we don't talk about
it or we like make it about people that
like live in mountains with crystals I
get it and usually they do go too far
hard right crystals you I saw that you
shouldn't have there to overprice but
you need them or something I saw it very
good the level of content I want to pump
out is extraordinary it's higher than
anybody here thinks hey are you wearing
a Jets hat
I know you're not named the Jets
offensive line get out of here I'll tell
you why we need it by the way
strictly for our lives I'll let these
guys help this way you can talk
it's nothing get you some time one Gibbs
one takes you guys should be able to
figure it out so what's your story
better so we started back in 2015 right
now we're seeing seven figures we're
pushing on to eight years pretty much
and trying to scale with is the scaling
problem infrastructure where people
probably a little bit of both make sense
right so what what can I answer as a
consumer yes
pay your bills yes I know nothing I know
nothing I see I know nothing okay I know
nothing about anything okay
but I'm a focus group of one like most
people do know what the [ __ ] they're
paying for things and care about stuff
right I hate everything that's
detail-oriented so my family you're like
my dad my brother my wife my account
like everybody but me knows that [ __ ]
okay no like I don't even know if I have
car insurance that was an actual
conversation I had this weekend Tyler
Tyler Alex was there an email that went
on about my car insurance this weekend
her did she take care of it herself but
that wasn't but that was a topic in the
last week right I'm not sure I'm not
sure I'm not joking so think about if I
don't do that right think about what I
know about like the Delta between what
I'm paying for energy or things of that
nature
right no idea I was just saying you know
possibly is there anything you know a
creative idea that's um oh I see no I'll
give you a good one I'll give you a
great one yeah you need to make Facebook
and Instagram videos with the cup with
the title did you know
and it says here's what I would do I
would run videos say did you know that
you could go on a free trip to Orlando
with your family and then the punch line
is if you switch to this energy because
then it would say on average and then
the bottom it would say on average a
family saves eighty eight dollars a
month times 12 is a thousand dollars the
average Disney trip for a family of four
is about you see where I'm going yeah
that [ __ ] kills okay getting people in
marketing together
oh yeah yeah like sup- like I know I
know what you're thinking that stuff is
too [ __ ] like hitting the lotto
versus like practical [ __ ] just like
you do sales right right like right it
works right yeah guess what else works a
marketing campaign that tells people
that if they switch they save this much
money and with that saved money they can
send their kid to private school they
can buy a boat they can go on a Disney
vacation they can eat a better lunch
once in a while do you see where I'm
going
like utilitarian like hey dick
don't be stupid switch to this it's 113
bucks a month
113 bucks a month times 12 1400 bucks
and then find 19 things in culture that
1,400 bucks buys you and then run
Instagram ads against people that are
fans of Supremes and Nikes and say do
you know that you could have 12 more
pairs of fly sneakers if you literally
just swiped up and click this button
okay guys I think we're gonna we're
gonna deploy immediately some of this
stuff but is there possibly one way we
can get a shout-out to all my guys wait
yes 100%
[Laughter]
but you gotta try
you have pretty timing Meg we're in a
great mood we couldn't be in a better
are they gonna be on my meeting it's so
weird I literally think of my business
meg do you know that that justjust like
war stories like literally in November
and December of Wine Library
well into like my late 20s I used to
like be there until two o'clock in
morning packing orders that's the best I
don't know of course you'd like it it's
your baby I really really think the
biggest thing that I took out of this
that I want you to think about and like
obviously like you know I can't speak
for ages time but mine's limited but I'm
happy to get on the phone with you when
I travel I like I I really think you
should think about selling it only
direct-to-consumer and select accounts a
la somebody comes in with that I think
it will work nice to get a 600 card here
from some eggs do you know why people
struggle with like direct-to-consumer
tampons or deodorant or all these like
Birchbox
why they struggle they all raise so much
money that they have they have to build
a five hundred million dollar company
for it all to work got it that is not
your ambition but Li
I actually think by not having that and
I'm not saying that's not your ambition
that is not your fit it's not your
ideology thus allowing you to
potentially by accident get the five
hundred million by doing it nice and
slow did the dirt you have one KPI
a couple hundred thousand in profit to
pay for eleven I I think you should
build a community of people that [ __ ]
care about you I think you should spend
two hours a day in forums to talk about
[ __ ] paper and become like like a og
of it so that they all like buy from you
you should sort of Facebook group
tomorrow around like what you know
whatever you call what you do is in your
way
and have 780 people in that talking
about cards and designs of paper and DUI
and all that look I'm telling you don't
get sucked up do you know why
vaynermedia built the Empire that you
referenced earlier I know nothing to
this day
about the advertising industry and you
know April I didn't pander to it what's
so interesting is the amount of sales
I've had today from wholesale and from
consumer is exactly the same like and
150 cents and the others a dollar on the
dollar
yeah you know it's a good example by the
way that's AJ because I would be an
eSports basketball and golf by now so
that's right though no I listen I
believe you we won't know the
alternative that's the beauty of the
game I'll take a lot a tie when your
chance Wow another stash why is it so
cold in my office oh is that true good
these greens are no joke it's any a
Twitter Twitter
yeah hey guys how are you
which one like what people understand
there's a lot of people that made all
this money they were high risk like
there's like six instagrams
yeah and uber lyft there's like six of
those you know that's why I'm becoming
outrageously practical like I think it's
practical in your late 20s to move back
in with your parents the only reason
you're not is you hate your parents or
you worry about what other people think
otherwise it's [ __ ] I wish I was with
my parents now I love my parents it's
cozy as [ __ ] everything my wife asks me
to do my mom would do for me if she was
there I love the summer when we're kind
of more together that's the [ __ ] you
know I think it's practical like I can't
think of an easier way to make 200 bucks
than the garage sale and thrift I need
you d-roc Andy I need an Andy I'll take
a Tyler - I want to do something very
important here a Tyler a Dirac and an
Andy a synth - yeah just bring them all
in I really like bring those characters
here very quickly and this is why I
brought you in core
and work with him producthunt there's
gonna be things we can manipulate
distribution and of that video that
within 80 seconds the word on the
streets being like get a [ __ ] meeting
with Gary Vee who cares
you're gonna get because everyone's
gonna watch it the end oh the most fun
I've had in a long time it's the only
thing I care about so but it's the only
thing I care about
and they've sucked for the last two
years so it's like three years of
pent-up energy Andy I want us to start
posting the daily be episode immediately
on Twitter through the team not me and
making a native like clip of the video
that's long like I like the idea of like
a minute 32 two minutes of whatever clip
so not a BSU for it but a native face
Twitter thing because that's working
better but just raw video from a scene
from it like something that will tease
people to want to watch the rest yes
when we can but if it's like 29 you know
can you go full is there a limit on the
full cool so the answer is wonder under
10 minutes yes when or not I like the
idea of making a minute 32 two minutes
max as a teaser and like have May or
whoever I like like got it because also
pushing right when it goes up helps the
YouTube algorithm yeah I mean I don't
need to yeah exactly like like here's
and like I'll create default copy for
the team like here's two minutes let's
do that done here's two minutes from
today's episode click here to watch the
full got it starting tomorrow
who won the New York Jets Detroit Lions
game last night
last night the Jets beat the Lions 48 to
17 yeah they did
that third quarter though wise walks up
through this though why they showed up
last time way yeah showing you the next
games please tell me you saw this clip
on NFL Network today sorry Marcus yeah
we're ruining your meeting which is
obviously very important but I can't I
guess it's not here I'll actually hear
it
you just have to watch us as like a
sports fan like imagine this imagine
this happened in mixed you know what
happened through interception for a
touchdown the first pass either only two
other people have ever done it and enjoy
the sport how about my Jets huh you
should take a nice a acro well instead
of Bilal pal no no I think Bulow is
still gonna have monster man that was
fun you forget how much fun it is when
you've had like two or three years of
not anything I just want you to give
them a little context from the horse's
mouth
oh this is for we basically feel that
it's working so why fix it but at the
same time it's just a lot and it's not
necessarily the best it's not like we
can't get your Gator be Chinese verify
because you're Gary is verified and they
say you can't have multiple people
verify then yeah so we're challenging
them yeah
Sam yeah I think that is like flirting
with Andy's head and I I just want to
remind him that we we don't want to do
that and we want to do our own thing and
I'm joking a little bit like here's my
big thing let me say my big thing my big
thing is that like I had a really really
weird epiphany this morning I'm like oh
man like text messaging is really really
important for Wine Library I guess
here's where I'm going I'm going a
totally the upper place I realized
without realizing and now I've realized
it you know use the three months yeah I
assume like every culture in the world
you have other homies that can develop
in the exact nature if I gave you money
like freelance money to put on one of
your buddies to like team do you have a
buddy I assumed so the thought if I'm
like hey this is so [ __ ] important
actually I should really be thinking
about this as a 30-day thing not a you
know I love how we do it and I love you
get like it was funny I'm like I love
the fact that he'll get all the
experience for himself for us but like
I'm probably in a place where like if we
get in there like first of all we should
definitely get in there like tell me how
what I need to do but like I'd love to
get you two to team up and say like okay
cool we can hire and by the way you have
sense it's like maybe there's like maybe
they want to work at uber or like
whatever to trade is money and something
else like I think I really want this
thing fast and awesome and so like by
way you could also come back to me earn
so many stripes with me you're like yo
bro I really want this for me and do it
all like cuz I just want to taste
everything like even as bad as I wanted
two months earlier I probably would
probably say yes cuz I want to like
support you
so can you marinate on all that data
[Music]
1:37 p.m. the Japanese bike by the way
did you see it it's so nailed that the
spike in interest exploded in Japan it
was like this hockey second now did you
graduate from high school with somebody
famous think like you know we got a QR
code here like right now honestly I want
know honestly if you told me you guys
were sitting there and setting up in the
best way we've ever seen with me
creating content in a world raw I want
to click a button with the flights that
I have coming up like if we go through
October now to October and actually I
click over 50,000 times an email I think
we're gonna feel really good you know
I'd really like to do that YouTube
what's up thank you so much for watching
my videos you're gonna get right to it
but real quick September 24th a
ridiculous ridiculous event here at
vaynermedia this is your time to come a
barter offer Mike a Swiss oh oh three s
which I'm not wearing I'm wearing some
other case buses right now but right
good the case Widow bag paste with a oh
three barter party 50 pairs right gets
you the party 50 pairs up click the link
it's Gary Vee slash barter or if this is
an ad swipe up or if there's a length of
the link or this is a YouTube pre-roll
just like it's Gary Vee slash Barner for
details on the party the event the
networking the time with me on September
24th New York City be there get the
details in the action that's needed to
get the details see ya
[Music]